hey this is pressed Elle Walker and
you're watching mind your decisions
here's a really fun geometry problem a
semicircle is inscribed in a quarter
circle as illustrated what fraction of
the quarter circle is shaded in red
I think Liam from the UK for sending me
this problem which comes from the UK MT
and I admit I struggled for about 30
minutes before I figured it out so I
suggest you give the problem a serious
effort before watching the solution can
you figure it out give this problem a
try and when you're ready keep watching
the video for a solution so how can we
solve this problem well sometimes when
you're stuck it helps to set up a goal
and then work backwards so let's set up
an equation for the fraction that is
shaded that'll be equal to the area of
the semicircle divided by the area of
the quarter circle now we can write
equations for each of these areas if we
know the radius of each of these shapes
so let's define some variables let Q
equal the radius of the quarter circle
and then let s equal the radius of the
semicircle now the area of the
semicircle is equal to 0.5 pi s squared
and then the area of the quarter circle
will be equal to 0.25 pi Q squared we
can cancel out the PI's and then 0.5
divided by 0.25 is equal to 2 so this
simplifies to be 2 s squared over Q
squared so we want a relationship
between the values s squared and Q
squared and notice there is no need to
solve for s and Q because eventually we
have to square the values of s and Q so
with that said how can we solve for a
relationship between Q and s well one
thing you can do in geometry problems
like this is
try and connect interesting points with
line segments what would happen if I
connect the center of the semicircle and
draw a radius to the tangency of the
quarter circle so what would happen if I
drew one of these lines since the
semicircle is tangent to the quarter
circle this is a right angle and the
line segment will have a value that's
equal to the radius of the semicircle so
it's equal to s now we can also draw
this line segment which will also be
tangent and it will also have the value
of s now since the quarter circle is 90
degrees this is also a right angle and
therefore in this quadrilateral all of
the angles must be right angles which
means this shape defines a square so all
sides are equal to s furthermore the
diagonal of this square will be equal to
s times the square root of two because
we have a 45-45-90 right triangle now
let's continue connecting important
points in this diagram let's draw a
radius of the quarter circle through the
center of the semicircle because each of
these is a radius of the semicircle each
will be equal to s therefore the radius
of this quarter circle bisects the chord
of this quarter circle and therefore
these meet at a right angle now in the
quarter circle let's draw another radius
to where the diameter of the semicircle
intersects the quarter circle because
this is a radius of the quarter circle
its value will be equal to Q now what we
can do is we can notice there's a right
triangle here and we can use the
Pythagorean theorem so we have s times
the square root of 2 that quantity
squared plus s squared is equal to Q
squared and this simplifies to be 3 s
squared is equal to Q squared and that's
the relationship we need to solve this
problem so we go back to what we derived
before and now we substitute in that 3 s
squared is equal to Q squared so we
simplified this fraction to
squared all over 3s squared and we get
the answer of two over three and that's
the answer did you figure it out thanks
for watching this video these math
videos which can be watch for free on
YouTube inspire and build confidence for
people around the world and they already
have over a hundred million views please
subscribe for free to get the news
videos and Emily a puzzle or mat topic
presh
and mind your decisions comm if you so
choose you can check out my merchandise
which is listed on teespring you can
check out my books which are listed in
the video description and you can
support me on patreon for exclusive
rewards thanks for watching and thanks
for your support